♪♪
-Cheers, everybody.
How about this? 50.
This is 50 "Corrections."
-If you had told me
when we started
that we would do
50 "Corrections,"
I would have said, "Yeah, I
guess so. I mean, why not?
I mean, I'm the only one
who does anything."
[ Light laughter ]
Like, I like it.
Hey, I said the Jackal
was an acronym for.
Jerks Attempting Comedy-Killing
Absent Love.
And I was told
that's a "back-cronym,"
which is when you create
an acronym based on
an existing word.
Basically someone said
that I deliberately
worked Backwards from Jackal.
That's not how it happened.
You remember, Shoemaker -- I
came -- I went in --
The first time
I read any of your comments,
marched right over
to Shoemaker's office,
and I said,
I got a bunch of jerks
attempting comedy,
killing absent love.
And then you were
the one who was like, "Oh."
And remember?
And then I went, "Oh."
And then you were like,
"Oh-oh-oh."
And then I said, "Ah!"
And that's how
we came up with it.
My favorite thing this week is
someone by accident --
On accident --
Let me know.
[ Laughter ]
If someone accidentally...called
Shoemaker, "butter maker."
[ Laughter ]
Which is funny because
"Butter Maker" is his alter ego.
-Because Shoemaker used to --
not any more after the leg.
But Shoemaker used to drink
and black out.
And then the next day you'd go
in his office and [Bleep]
would be off the walls and you
say, "What happened?"
He goes, "I think
Butter Maker was here."
[ Light laughter ]
"Oops."
He doesn't really --
[ Laughs ]
Oops!
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of butter maker,
if you think 1976 is
bad news bears is a movie
you can show kids today.
I got some bad news, Bears.
I don't even think
you can show them the trailer.
Oh, I said -- I referred to
somebody bringing a turntable
to a party as being a deejay.
I was told
by a bunch of people
that if someone shows up
with one turntable
they are not a deejay.
So don't let
that person into your house.
If they show up with two
turntables and a mixer,
Then they are a deejay.
And don't let that person
into your house.
[ Laughter ]
The Titanic was a ship,
I referred to it as a boat.
On the upside,
not the worst thing
that happened to the Titanic.
[ Laughter ]
"The New York Times" Mini.
The mini crossword puzzle,
a lot of you brought this
to my attention
and this as an answer.
Plastic toy, bricks.
And the answer is Legos.
Well, I don't need to tell you.
I mean, we, we set off on this
journey of 50 episodes
when we were told
there's no plural for Legos.
You say Lego bricks.
Legos is incorrect.
But, you know, I would just say
to the to the Jackals out there,
you know, don't be --
it's just a mini.
Don't beat up on the mini.
"The New York Times" Mini
is interesting.
It is -- It's for people
who love puzzles.
But hate impressing people.
[ Laughter ]
Do you get the Mini today?
I mentioned Tintin.
Told I was
pronouncing it wrong.
Tintin is the Americanization.
In French,
you say, "Tonton."
That did -- It does seem a
little weird to my ear
to say "Tonton,"
after all these years.
But again, as fortune has it,
there is a person in my life
who is perfect to ask about
English versus French.
So I reached out
to my mom and asked
how she would say the
little boy, the, the traveler,
the journalist extraordinaire.
Mom, how would you say it?
-Kahn, kahn!
-Kahn-kahn.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, this was,
this was again, this was a
Jackals joke and I gave credit
about Nosfera-Chews--
the delicious candy.
And you know,
because I gave credit,
correctly,
the Jackals were celebrating
in the comment section
this week
That one of their own
had, had, had busted out.
And these were the, these
were the three comments
after someone said they
used my joke.
First person said, "The
Nosfera-Chews swelled feelings
of pride for the contributing
Jackal, well done."
Second person, "Nosfera-Chews
was major league funny.
You may make the bigs kid."
Very sweet.
Third one, "His name
isn't Nosfera-Chew, though.
Nosferatu, though
it's Count Orlok.
Nosferatu is the name
of the movie."
[ Laughter ]
And so for the Jackal,
who wrote that joke,
welcome to the roller coaster
that is my life.
Write a good joke, praise,
praise, Jackal ruins day.
It is right, though.
The character in Nosferatu,
the original one,
the F.W. Murnau was Count Orlok,
which I remembered,
because in the '80s
General Mills did a
German Expressionism serial
crossover and released this --
Count Chorlokula.
[ Laughter ]
I believe the term for it
is short lived.
Hey, uh, I want to apologize to
a couple of hot sauce companies,
Tabasco and Cholula.
During -- We went day drinking,
I went day drinking
with Post Malone and
there were two great hot sauces.
And while I was shaking out
the Cholula,
I called it Tabasco.
In my defense,
and there's no way anyone
watching that could have known
this, I had been drinking.
[ Laughter ]
We did a sketch called, uh,
"Best Case, Worst Case,"
which was had a lot of
bee content --
Content based on the insect.
More commonly known
as the Bee.
And. well,
there were some problems.
First there was the line
first graphics had an issue,
which we said, uh,
bees blotted out the Sun.
And, you know, when when
anything blots out the Sun,
the idea is that
they cover the sky.
There are so many of them
the sky, you can't see the Sun.
Whereas graphics thought bees
just swarmed to the sun.
And, like, landed on it.
However you want to think that,
because, of course,
that wouldn't,
as a lot of you pointed out,
the bees would, you know,
they would, they'd incinerate.
[ Laughter ]
Jermaine wrote -- our writer
Jermaine wrote this sketch
and he's a -- he's usually got
a good attention to detail.
Now, again, in his defense.
I think the first draft of this
was only written 18 months ago.
[ Light laughter ]
So there wasn't a ton
of time, you know.
Dot the I's and cross the T's.
So there were a few --
There were a few of you
who knew a little bit more
about bees than anybody --
it was just a few.
Male bees don't have stingers,
that's one.
When the queen dies,
the drones don't also die,
they rear a new queen.
[ Bees buzz ]
[ Light laughter ]
Bees don't die when they lose
their stingers that's wasps.
That's three.
[ Bees buzz ]
Bees don't say "buzz"
that's the sound
their wings make when they fly.
That's four.
[ Bees buzz ]
Queen bees can't five -- fly.
Five. [ Laughs ]
[ Bees buzz ]
You showed a picture
of a wasp not a bee.
[ Bees buzz ]
Bees would be able to blot out
the Sun --
Oh, not just because they
wouldn't blot out the Sun,
they can't survive in space.
That's seven. Yeah.
[ Bees buzz ]
And then the final correction
was one that really
wasn't even bee related about
this wonderful sketch
that Jermaine wrote.
Correction, this was not
supposed to air.
[ Laughter ]
You know, I mentioned that we
don't get a lot of fan art
and I think a lot of you took
it the wrong way.
I don't remember saying this
because, you know, again,
I was fishing for it,
but I guess a lot of you
heard we don't get a lot
of Wally fan art.
[ Light laughter ]
I don't know what it is about
Wally, but people are,
people are drawn to him.
-You know.
-Maybe he's born with it.
"Maybe it's Wabelline."
[ Laughter ]
We talked about Wally "Two
Trees" Feresten
and, and and this meme
that somebody made.
And there were two things
that were pointed out to me
that I got to say are fair,
one
while he's holding the cue card
that says Seth sucks.
Someone said,
But you read what he says.
So technically it should say,
"I suck."
I think that's right,
but would have been confusing.
Also, someone said, "At no point
would I have said that
Tony Soprano's nickname was
'Da Boss.'"
[ Laughter ]
And then someone said
they came up
with a better nickname for Wally
than Wally Two Trees Feresten.
And I love
Wally Two Trees Feresten.
And I thought, I bet you don't.
And then they told me.
And I will say,
I laughed when I read it.
Wally Paulnuts.
[ Laughter ]
They also said
Mike "Tank-top" Scollins.
It should be if you have no, no
trees, it should be
Mike "No-sleeves" Scollins.
We had a pretty great crew.
Mikey No-sleeves,
Butter Maker, Wally Paulnuts,
and Jermaine "Refuses
To Google Bee Facts."
We called him that because he
refused to Google bee facts.
[ Light laughter ]
Speaking of speaking
of no sleeves, Scollins,
he had a joke about
a Guinness World Record
being set for the largest
chicken nugget ever made.
That was the setup.
To put it in joke parlance.
[ Laughter ]
And then the punch line
was and now for the bad news.
And we showed a picture
of Big Bird.
And many of you took offense,
and many more of you said,
"Big Bird is a canary,
not a chicken.
So the joke doesn't work."
Because if there's one thing we
know, chicken nuggets
[As Big Bird]
only have chicken.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
This is just a genuine question
I have to our our European --
our international viewers.
Talked about the sexy
firefighter calendar and how
it started on Monday
and calendars start on Sunday.
But it seems like,
everywhere but America,
they start on Monday.
So people said you were fine,
you didn't need to correct that.
The question I have is,
does the rest of the world
have sexy firefighter calendars?
We'll post a poll.
Don't answer if you're not from
out of the country.
Doesn't work
and we stop taking it seriously.
Oh, I talked about Paul Revere
charging for his midnight ride,
you know, because he had
all these expenses,
like he was using his own horse.
and a bunch of you said,
not only do you not use his own
horse, he borrowed a horse
and he never brought it back.
So I guess Paul Revere
is canceled now.
[ Laughter ]
When does it stop?
Pizza Hut.
Our friends at Pizza Hut, they
sent they sent us free pizza
today for our staff
and our crew.
Such a nice gesture --
Also this week,
Little Caesars replaced
Pizza Hut as the official pizza
of the NFL.
And I just pray those.
two aren't related.
That someone at Pizza Hut said,
"I'd love to send pizza to
the team over at 'Late Night'"
and then, you know, their boss
said, "Okay, but you gotta find
the money somewhere else.
[ Laughter ]
Because that's what
I'm hoping, right?
I'm hoping that Pizza Hut
opted out
of being the official pizza
of the NFL.
I don't know the story about it,
but I'd hate to think
they were still trying to.
Look, I just don't want to
live in a world
where they got out pizza'd.
[ Laughter ]
But maybe that's what --
maybe they opted out.
Because they want --
they are over the official pizza
of the NFL maybe they want to be
the official
pizza of "Corrections."
We're in talks.
[ Laughter ]
And I don't think
we have the reach.
I'm not going to sit here and
lie to you and say
we've got the reach or
the scope of the NFL.
But let me say something,
50 episodes.
50 episodes, not one concussion.
[ Laughter ]
And we go hard.
Remember that movie
"Concussion"?
Where there was a doctor who
taught everybody
The trauma one could receive
with with a blow to the head.
How traumatic
a blow to the head --
Do you remember who played
the doctor? Will Smith.
Foreshadowing.
Oh, by the way, I knew about
the Little Caesars news,
because of there was
a PR press release.
My PR was public relations.
They had this press release
from Little Caesars
explaining how they're and, and
I think we can all agree
just by looking at it, too long.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, I was told that people
from Queens never say Queens.
They would say "Astoria"
or "Long Island."
But I just want to say
to all of them.
Behind your back,
we say Queens.
♪♪
Someone said, "Your
O.J. impression was terrible."
Well, I'll make sure to
lean into it next time.
[ Laughter ]
Hey,
when I think we're a month out
from getting the merch.
Here's the thing,
when the merch is ready,
you guys got to buy the merch,
okay?
I've been making a big deal
about the merch
and I'm calling up the merch
people and making a stink
every day and if you guys don't
buy the merch,
I'm not going to be able
to look them in the eye
when I see them at the
commissary, buy the merch.
If I go down to
the NBC Experience Store
and the merch
is in the discount bin
with the you know, "Where in the
World is Matt Lauer"
beer cozies --
[ Laughter ]
Um, I want to read a comment.
Someone left a comment,
a critical comment,
but it made me think and --
Again, this whole thing,
all jokes aside,
it is about improvement.
I want to be better. and I
appreciate the time
all of you Jackals take to
engage with the show.
I hope you know that.
Every now and then maybe I come
off as a little surly.
But you take time,
I take the time to read them.
I think we both
come out of it better.
So this is a critical comment
and I want to read it
'cause it made me think
and I'm going to read it --
I'm going to use a voice
when I read it.
And I don't want you
to think the voice is me
editorializing about
the comment.
The voice I use is completely
unconnected to how I feel
about what you took
the time to write, okay?
[Strange British-like voice]
The less political relevance
this show has the less funny
and interesting it becomes.
"Corrections" is always a word
salad of unfunny, puns,
quirky nonsense
that amounts to obnoxious
Internet banter
and nothing more.
Can't you correct
the Republican Party?
Or something worthwhile?
This is so meaningless,
it makes me not laugh
again and again.
[ Normal voice ]
So just thank you.
[ Laughter ]
Taking the time to write
something so important.
Um --
This is a, this is 50,
but next week is the
this -- the spec-jack-ular
jack-tacular?
We'll have, uh...
Let's have Peacock
do some market research.
"Jack-tacular"
or "Spec-jack-ular"?
And it's, it's gonna be big.
[ Light laughter ]
It's gonna be
really, really big.
It's, um, we are um...
We spent a lot of money on it.
And I think when you tune in,
you're going to be blown away.
Right off the jump.
There is...
you know, obviously,
we no longer use live
animals on the show.
So that, that whole element
of it has to be CGI.
[ Light laughter ]
Rehearsals, whew.
The rehearsals are intense.
So do, do please come back in a
week for that.
But thank you for being here
for the 50th.
I think this was by far, you
know, Top 25.
[ Light laughter ]
You, will see me next week.